Tonight, debris
from a US Patriot
missile raining down on a street in Kyiv.
The stunning video proving that
the most sophisticated air
defense system in the world
was used to stop Russia
when it fired
11 cruise and ballistic missiles
at the Ukrainian capital this week.
This comes as Yevgeny
Prigozhin, the head of the Russian
private army,
the Wagner group,
lashed out in a response
to a question
from CNN about
whether he would be holding
a press conference in Russia.
We got booms, really.
We are getting ready for a long,
hard war.
Really, the fireworks datacentre,
they see him
in the first message to CNN
is that you have to respect Russia.
Your visit with him right now.
Prigozhin went on to issue
a violent threat.
Violent and graphic threat.
Certainly not the first time
that Prigozhin has lashed out,
of course, under pressure.
The war he is fighting
has caused that pressure, right.
Making its way deeper
into Russian territory.
Drone and artillery attacks
inside the country are on the rise
so much
that Vladimir
Putin's top propagandist
is now saying that nuclear weapons
should be used
to destroy Elon Musk's
StarLink satellites,
which is the crucial technology
that Ukraine
is believed to use
to launch drone strikes
There's two parter.
I think it's time to turn up the heat.
We understand that all drones
and everything else works
for Americans only while StarLink exists.
So if we carefully launch
our nukes into space,
then there will be no StarLink left.
Sam Kiley is OUTFRONT
Ukraine's not claiming
responsibility for these attacks
inside Russia.
But if Kiev gets blamed,
that's just fine.
There's more to come.
Ivan, you've said that it's a vulnerable
to what one of say there.
The number of incidents
is constantly increasing,
not only in the border areas,
but also in the depths of Russia.
It's already happening.
The scale will be exponential here.
An oil
refinery in Russia's far
south is set aflame
while along Ukraine's
northern border with its invader,
civilian areas are hit by shelling
apartments riddled
with shrapnel commonplace in Ukraine.
A new experience for Russians.
Ukraine's new strategy is taking shape
inside Russia.
Drone and artillery attacks
have hit Russian targets
in an arc along
its Ukrainian border provinces
of Bryants,
Kursk, Belgorod, Verona and Krasnodar.
And Moscow's not been spared either
on the deck of a Royal Navy warship.
Key Ukrainian ally,
the United Kingdom,
gave Kiev a green light to attack Russia.
Legitimate military
targets beyond its own
border
are part of Ukraine's self-defense.
And we should recognize eyes.
We should recognize that.
In response,
former Russian
president and close
Putin ally Dmitri Medvedev
claimed on Twitter
that as the UK is in an undeclared war
against Russia,
any British official
could be considered
as a legitimate military target.
Now, that would be an escalation
even Vladimir Putin might resist
Now, Erin,
you mentioned the use of nuclear weapons
against StarLink satellites there.
That would be,
I think, technically impossible.
I have to say also locally,
they're not used by drones,
certainly not drones
that could strike
as deep into Russia as Moscow.
But this
I think,
should be seen
what we're seeing in Russia
as a completely new phase
of the Ukrainian strategy.
This could be effectively
what we've all been talking about,
which is the beginning
of their counteroffensive.
They're launching it
and they're launching it in Russia, Erin.
And so well said.
All right. Sam, thank you very much.
On the ground in Ukraine tonight.
And OUTFRONT now,
I want to go to Andrei Soldatov,
a Russian investigative journalist.
His latest article details
the Kremlin's
panic over
the increasing number of anti-Putin,
Russian exiles living abroad.
So, Andre,
I want to play more from Prigozhin,
who told CNN that he and his allies
speak directly to the Russian people
because he says
Russian state
media is trying to hide
the true reality of the war.
Let me play another brief
clip here for you.
Gotta remember, I'm sure I do.
We discuss how to best convey
an honest agenda
to the Russian Federation population
about what is happening
So as on the one hand, not to so panic.
And on the other hand,
to mobilize society
and not to mollify it as some,
including the federal media
are currently doing
Andre,
what do you think he is doing here?
Well, first of all,
we all understand that
Prigozhin are already,
as has his media empire.
He has he has troll factories.
He is recording his videos
almost on a daily basis.
So obviously,
he has no communication problems.
So it is about something else.
And I suspect
that he is sensing that Vladimir Putin
very soon will have no choice
but to start preparing the country
to entering into the next stage
to switch to the warmer and full vats
that there would be a substantial effort
to including mobilization
and tightening and rules
And it's quite obvious that
because on the wants
to be part of this effort and he is
he does has his own ideas, for instance
to mobilize
leads by sending kids to the battlefield.
So he is he's very resourceful.
So in your new article,
you talk about
a growing number of anti-Putin
Russian exiles and that the Kremlin
is is very afraid of this
and has been attempting
to stoke a paranoia
among them, perhaps, of what's
killing them.
Or poisonings
or who know what it what it may be,
but that the Kremlin
has this worry of enemies
plotting abroad.
What more are you learning
Well, they say that
that is a combination of things.
First of all,
this attacks on Moscow
has a huge, profound psychological effect
on Muscovites and on the Russian elites.
Everybody immediately remembers that.
23 years ago, while
what happened last year
pushing to become president was fear felt
by many Muscovites,
because back then
and I remember that vividly
there was a serious attack
on civilians in Moscow.
So Putin promised the Russians
to protect them.
And that is why so many Russians
decided to sacrifice
a liberties, civil liberties
and exchange for this protection.
And now that is not protection,
and that is no liberties.
And everybody understands that,
including the Kremlin.
That is why they're getting paranoid.
And we hear
reports about more poisonings
and more attacks
on Russian political opposition
in exile.